today we're talking about security cdn
and bigquery
i am priyanka vergaria and welcome to
this week in cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news from the safety
of home
in these virtual times everyone is
getting used to the new technology and
working remotely
that's why it's even more important for
companies to look at a zero trust
model and the philosophies of beyond
corp now we are working with
even more partners to support devices
networks
and just about everything else to keep
your teams and organizations secure
cdns are vital for fast and reliable
content delivery
and now we're making cloud cdn easier
and cheaper to use
with an 80 reduction on fetching content
from your origin
and no cash to cash fill charges it's
definitely something you will want to
try out to
improve your app's performance check out
the updated features and pricing details
throughout october and november google
cloud is offering
no cost data analytics training no
matter if you've just started learning
how to get insights from your data
or you already have significant data
analytics experience
take your skills to the next level with
this collection of different training
opportunities
once you're ready go for the google
cloud data engineering certification to
show off your professional skills
migrating to the cloud is easy to talk
about but getting started is a whole
different story
that's why i've created this collection
of migration strategies to help you plan
and walk through your cloud migration
journey we've even put together a
one-on-one video series to kick-start
your migration
so what are you waiting for if you want
to read more about these announcements
or see a full list
check out the links any thoughts or
ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you